so first I'll go straight there my niece
is just discovering movies now that's
four and the thought that any movie that
she sees at this point could be the one
that she looks back on and think to
herself like that is the first time I
understood the power of movie Magic just
it fills my heart yeah so what is that
movie for you the first movie you can
remember just like fully enveloping you
and transporting you into a world that
like maybe isn't real but made you
believe spirit
spirit with the horse I think is Spirit
DreamWorks I think it might be original
I know that the the new spirit was
DreamWorks but Spirit was the first
movie that I ever saw period in a
theater I think I was like
I was really young I was six six maybe
or maybe yeah maybe maybe even like five
or four and
I just like remember
I think seeing it in the theater and
like I didn't even know like a screen
could be that big you know like when
you're a kid and it was so like integral
to like who I have like the just like
how free that like freeing that movie
was was like amazing I'm excited for you
I'm excited for you you said yes oh yeah
that's a fun time she just sat through
all of The Little Mermaid and it made me
so happy and it signaled Now's the Time
it begins and that's what the ant is
here for yes very good I love that so I
want to talk a little bit about your
voice acting experience because you have
had some before so can you give me maybe
a shared quality between all of the
voice acting gigs you've had that you
have appreciated but then on top of that
I also want something unique to
DreamWorks that made this process stand
out what made what was unique to
DreamWorks and made this
project Stand Out was that
was time
I had a lot of time to record this so we
I recorded over the course of like three
years versus the other animation that
I've done before like it's pretty short
like I'm I'm in and out and and we're
done but this was over three years and
what I really really learned was like
the importance of
um like warming up your voice and
protecting like protecting your voice
because when you're in a booth for like
four five six hours talking talking
screaming at like Ruby Goodman there's a
lot of like ah you really want to like
really warm up your voice protect your
voice like conserve it when you don't
have to speak
um because there were a couple days
where like if I didn't do that I'd get
into the booth I'd be like oh no hear it
you know so you know but I think it's
always it's always been like making sure
I warm up and stuff like that oh I have
so many follow-up questions right now
first because you mentioned it was a
three-year process for you like how how
was the work spread out over those three
years were you revisiting scenes as they
were retooling things in the animation
realm yes we were constantly going back
like we I mean I never we were never
doing it in order like we were always
basically recording to like what
production needed like what all the
artists were doing this scene so they
really needed my voice in it
um and then they would rework it so I
would do the scenes over and over again
like over the months and whatnot
um and it was it was the process was
really cool because I loved I loved
being able to revisit a scene too
because you're like oh like I I can make
it better or I can you know what what
not but yeah animation is a whole other
it's a whole other world than live
action magicians
rather and spend years working on this
thing everyone's work comes together
seamlessly I know it's wild I went to
the crew screening of Ruby Roman teenage
Kraken and there was like hundreds of
crew members like from all the different
art departments and lighting and
everything and you're just like this is
really amazing like just how many people
it takes to make something like so
wonderful and it's so cohesive if you
could learn more about one person on the
production's job in any Department you
want which would you pick and why I
don't know what the name of this is but
I was just actually watching a interview
of I don't know what his title was on
our film but they animate the clothes
and he was saying that the clothes are
all like knit because the Gilman's like
reach their arms and their legs a lot
and they're super super bendy so the
clothes reach with them it's not like
how like if I'm go like this the clothes
are like this like the clothes also move
and I think that I would love to know
more about like how did you do that like
how did you make that so real the level
of detail is yeah absolutely wild yeah
back to your voice performance this this
question could get weird but I have a
question about efforts yeah I want to
know which type of effort comes to you
most naturally where it's the easiest
thing for you to replicate but then I
also want the one that is the hardest
the thing that we do in everyday life
but is just so difficult to replicate in
your session an amazing question a thank
you
um the easiest for me is like
um is the effort of becoming overwhelmed
and I think that's just because like me
as like a human like I get overwhelmed a
lot and so it's like kind of second
nature
um but that effort of like
like all of that like is it comes
naturally to me and the hardest effort
for me would be
um
we didn't really do this effort in Ruby
Goldman teenage Kraken but I have done
voiceover before
um and the hardest is making out
because what you don't realize is you
make out
with your hand
it's so gross and so you're like here's
the you know the mic is there and
there's your hand and you have to like
extra like make your like oh it's so
gross and you're making out with your
hand and everyone's watching you in the
what is my
problem asked you this question it would
get weird yeah that's the hardest
hardest effort to do mainly because I'm
just so uncomfortable in the worst
transition ever I'll end on a more
wholesome yeah so this movie is all
about you know Ruby finding her voice
finding her power I want to turn that
towards you as an actor do you remember
the first project you were on that you
know showed you the power of your own
voice that acting wasn't just about
reading the lines on the page but if you
had an idea you could speak up about it
people would listen and it could change
a project for the better that's a great
question I think that that's always like
the
that is always like the goal at least
for me as an Entertainer to like get to
that place because I think we we like
early on in my career that was I never
felt like really empowered to like make
a suggestion or like maybe I I was
definitely still trying to find my voice
um I think
I think now I don't know if it's
necessarily a specific I just finished a
project actually um we shot half of it
in Malaysia
um and I felt very empowered on that
film
um I I it's rom-com esque and I act and
I'm I love rom-coms I've done a lot of
them and so I felt that the production
was like asking me
advice into how to make a successful
rom-com and that actually like I was
really kind of I was flattered I was
like thank you so much for asking me
that I felt very empowered on that set
but I felt very empowered on this set
and I'm at a point now in my career and
in my life where I feel like
I I know my worth and I know my
boundaries and like I'm I'm happy to say
what's on my mind as you should I'm glad
Productions are recognizing that huge
congratulations on Ruby Gilman thank you
I hope you're I hope your niece likes it